[Musique]
bonsoir tous nos amis
bonsoir les écoliers mais où vas-tu avec
ce cartable nounours à l'école cher
patron
[Musique]
ça fait 8 battants mais non ça fait 6 ça
fait ça les enfants
bonsoir les écoliers
[Musique]
je viens me perfectionner en votre
compagnie
et travail sérieusement au boulot je
vais faire des multiplications
[Musique]
il suffit tout simplement de se conduire
gentiment quand on va à l'école on
s'assie sur un banc et tout ça qu'on
apprend et tellement intéressant que
tout le monde est content où faut-il
donc aller quand on veut s'amuser à la
jolie école à la grande maison où l'on a
des crayons où l'on fait de beaux pâtons
ou l'enchante des chansons
voilà gentille école les défis de garçon
on apprend des leçons on joue avec des
ballons
pendant les réactions
des grands et des petits et du
professeur aussi qu'on aimera toutes sa
vie il vivait l'école nous aime aussi y
aller pour les calculer pour y répondre
pour dessiner pour pas vrai pour
colorier
et voilà j'ai terminé mon travail
qu'en pensez-vous
superbe tu es très fort n'est-ce pas
j'ai toujours été le premier de ma
classe moi
il ne vous reste plus qu'à suivre mon
bon exemple
allons au lit l'école c'est fatiguant
ma parole c'est vrai
bonne nuit le petit
à demain
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants allez vite vous
coucher car il faut se lever de bonne
heure pour aller à l'école
[Musique]
pardon patron tu as bien travaillé je
n'ai pas fait une seule faute j'ai faim
de multiplication difficile
on y va en route
à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]